we know that it's not just la closing
down again Texas the great state of
Texas is locking down again Republican
governor there I don't know they're just
they're going along with it they don't
want the mean articles in the New York
Times they don't want to withstand the
the attacks from the left that are
obviously going to keep ramping up
through November 3rd Texas is locking
down again with one exception and that
would be vanilla ice yes there are many
things that are surprising one vanilla
ice is still performing all those years
all those decades after Ice Ice Baby
but Vanilla Ice gets a pass why because
the the concert venue that he's going to
be performing in is the islands two or
three thousand seat place but it's
primarily a restaurant so they've even
though the bars and everything we're
closing down somehow there is a loophole
here and vanilla ice gets to continue to
perform and the saddest part of all of
this is that Vanilla Ice has a better
understanding of politics and medicine
than most elected Republicans and
certainly than the governor of his state
that's it's weep for your country folks
when Vanilla Ice understands more about
politics than your elected leaders
Democrats understand a lot about
politics and I think they understand
about medicine - I think they're lying
for political ends and I think they are
lying shamelessly and the the double
standard and the apocrypha is so
transparent but they do understand that
they know what they're doing it's the
Republicans that are driving me so crazy
here because they're just allowing the
Democrats to do it consider this
everything that we have seen from a
political standpoint in the last three
months is almost created in a laboratory
I don't know about a laboratory in wuhan
but a laboratory in some political
scientists basement to help Joe Biden
and to hurt Donald Trump you know Joe
Biden's gonna try to get out of the
debates or make the debates more of a
virtual kind of thing that will give him
a benefit they have a candidate who
can't campaign so what they do they
cancel the campaign they have an
opponent
an incumbent president Donald Trump who
holds these massive great rallies so
what do they do cancel the rallies they
have a candidate who makes a lot of
gaffes right he just if Joe Biden were
on the campaign trail right now he'd be
making ten gaffes a day at least so what
do they do they lock him in a basement
they had any coming with the best
economy in the history of the world what
do they do crash the economy and then
when we flatten the curve we do
everything they say for the medical
science there's there is no more medical
or scientific argument they can make
what do they do they say yeah we're
gonna do it again anyway why not because
you're not gonna stop as Republicans
because you're a bunch of dummies
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoice a software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description